les bons choix soit vous êtes grand
reporter au figaro
vous avez publié plusieurs essais vous
avez publié un roman chez plon qui
s'appelle dandy rouge en 99 vous avez
fait un ouvrage sur la presse people et
les paparazzis avec patrick poivre
d'arvor qui s'appelle les rats de garde
chez stock
et aujourd'hui vous publié chez balland
parce que ça a été refusé par plombs on
peut le dire vous publié chez balland un
ouvrage qui s'appelle l'homme qui ne
s'aimait pas et qui consacrait au
président de la république jacques
chirac lors on comprend pourquoi plomb
l'a refusée c'est que plan est dit
bernadette chirac et ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent en ce moment est
gardée de chirac
peut-être qu'elle va faire un tome 2 ma
vie avec david douillet est donc et donc
ils se disent dans le fond ça serai
content perdre le business d'envié de
chez balland ce n'est pas plus mal toute
façon c'est comment on fait réglé mon
attention tout le monde le fait tout par
solidarité pour son camarade
très bien alors on dit toujours pourquoi
tu fais ça c'est ça dos et tout pas du
tout c'est pour montrer aux gens et sage
explique aussi c'est pour montrer aux
gens que quand on fait de la promo nous
on le dit voilà c'est tout tout seul que
léa drucker personne le fait alors
eczéma merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle pour votre première
télévision à partir de ce bouquin dont
on va beaucoup parler
ça a commencé cette semaine avec
l'observateur et le monde est à mon avis
c'est pas fini on va vous faire une
interview vérité on ne bouge pas pendant
les kings
bien c'est toute l'histoire de chirac
que vous racontez ça commence 156 le 17
mars 56 vous qui êtes un chiraquien vous
devez le savoir
c'est la date c'est la date du mariage
de jacques et bernadette malgré la
famille de bernadette c'est à dire que
les chodron de courcel n'était pas très
chaud pour qu'elle épouse un roturier
n'en aille c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire ouais et d'ailleurs tout le monde
dit depuis 30 ans qui s'est marié à
l'église sainte-colette id est en fait
il s'est marié dans la nex paris appelle
annexes parce que la belle famille
chodron de courcel ne supportait pas la
mésalliance way
et puis à sciences po ils ont préféré
une autre à sciences po il avait un
faible pour une maîtrise vindelle ouais
vous savez la grande famille me dira que
les nobles qui l'intéressent il ya que
les notes qui l'intéressait et
d'ailleurs quand il est parti aux états
unis vous savez il est et il était aussi
tombée amoureuse d'une américaine et
c'était une fille de sénateur alors
c'est là que vous dites pour la première
fois dans votre bouquin à ce moment là
vous dites que jacques chirac ne
s'aiment pas et c'est même le titre du
livre l'homme qui ne s'aimait pas et
vous dites qu'il est le premier à se
traiter de con à tout bout de champ moi
je croyais que c'était dans les guignols
genre que je suis con moi tout ça pas du
tout en fait il le dit écoutez je sais
c'est rare parce que c'est un type qui
est d'une lucidité et de même d'une
cruauté sur lui même tout à fait
incroyable pour la moyenne des gens mais
en particulier dans la classe politique
où les gens s'aiment bien où ils ont un
narcissisme incroyable giscard par
exemple les doigts parce que je
toucherai giscard balladur juppé tous
ces gens s'aiment beaucoup et chirac se
détestent ce dédaigne se méprisent
il passe son temps à dire qu'il est con
il parle ce qui est très intéressant ou
non est ce que très intéressant moi je
vous avez vu j'essaie de faire quasi
psychanalyse
parce que je crois qu'ils aient un
rapport avec le père qui est terrible le
père était était est un grand un grand
séducteur un homme vraiment un homme à
femmes et qui était assez brutale avec
lui même certains m'ont dit qu'ils ont
qu'il a eu qu ils humiliaient et je
crois qu'il a il a il a détruit la
confiance en lui du petit jacobs et sa
maman oui c'est vraiment la plaie
jacquet alors jacky justement à 18 ans
il a envoyé sur un cargo pour les
vacances son père voulait l'endurcir
justement tout à ça j'ai découvert par
sa mère qui l'avait dans les services
uniques bon exact est alors quand il est
sur le bateau il dit oui d'accord mais
je vais devenir capitaines au long cours
est en fait sous la pression familiale
il rentre louis le grand c'est même plus
que ça le r va le chercher à dunkerque
un escalier le prend par la peau des
fesses et il le ramène alors ça c'est un
truc aussi que vous trouvez récurrent
chez chirac c'est arrivé sur l'algérie
sur le pen sur l'europe sur la fracture
sociale on l'a vu le 26 octobre 95 quand
il a complètement changé de politique
vous dites il se dresse toujours contre
les notables contre l'ordre établi
mais en fait il revient toujours dans
les convenances et ce que j'appelle à un
rebelle de carte postale
ouais c'est un rigolo et hermès c'est
non non c'est très intéressant mais
c'est à dire c'est un type qui se
rebelle qui se révolte contre l'ordre
établi contre son père quoi en clair et
qui au dernier moment
ced ouais mais chodron de courcel c'est
pareil il voulait pas épouser et
finalement il épouse
ouais c'est pour ça que peut-être qu'il
a jamais divorcé mais tout à fait un
tout à fait moi on n'en est pas là pour
le moment au service militaire qu'il
fait à saumur et il est pas major eux
ils les majors oui mais on lui retire
parce que c'est le meilleur
ouais c'est le meilleur c'est il adore
l'armée lors d'un oui ces îles et il est
premier mais comme il a signé l'appel de
stockholm vous savez c'est un appel
pacifiste tout le monde aura oublié où
j'entendais faut le dire aux gens ça
beau fils avait été initiée par joliot
curie et par les communistes voilà en
fait c'était un action de propagande des
communistes contre l'armée américaine
oui mais à l'époque il ya plein de
jeunes gogo entre guillemets qui ont
signé en tant que pacifistes et comme il
a signé sam était en pleine guerre
froide
les militaires lui ont refusé le titre
de major d'accord alors ensuite bon bah
il fait l'algérie
l'ena ils adorent la job voilà mais il
sera jamais à la sortie de l'ena dans la
crème de la crème parce que voilà il
s'est quand même la crème de la crème
mais c'est un peu moins bien il a tourné
trois là il se retrouve à la cour des
comptes est absolument alors en 62 il
rejoint le cabinet de pompidou il dit à
olivier guichard
c'était ou low as ou pompidou j'ai
choisi pompidou mais de gaulle je m'en
fous le gaullisme c'est pas ma
génération en 62 ans est une phase
extraordinaire quand on sait que le
général de gaulle attise toutes les
passions à l'époque on est ou anti
gaulliste ou provost liste mais lui il
est ni l'un ni l'autre
rares étaient ceux qui s'en foutent et
les pour guichard olivier guichard qui
lui avait été un grand fidèle de charles
de gaulle pendant la traversée du désert
entre la fin de la guerre et 58 à un
guichet a été le seul à
colombey-les-deux-églises et guichard
dit ce type est un est un voyou l'a
toujours dit pour un refus à un voyou et
10 en plus qui s'habille sa peine ça
c'est une expression guichard que je
vraiment magnifique
quand il faut dire qu'un type et allah
est un russian et en même temps qu'il
devient qu'il n'est pas de son monde il
dit il s'habille à la samaritaine et
balladur a toujours pensé ça de chirac
dès les années 60 alors en continuant 74
chirac trail chaban pour faire élire
giscard parce qu'ils pensent que giscard
sera plus facile à manipuler finalement
que que chabran cessa pas chirac ne
pense pas ça c'est les mentors de chirac
qui pensent qu'ils pourront manipuler
qui s'appelait pierre juillet et marie
france garaud je pense qu'ils pourront
manipuler giscard et surtout ils
détestent chaban mais là il ya une
anecdote incroyable qui montre le
caractère de chirac qui était in oui je
pense
vous savez chaban-delmas déclare sa
candidature en 74 et le soir même une
voiture une déesse noire s'arrête devant
le domicile de monsieur chaban delmas
dans le 16e arrondissement cocarde d'une
déesse noire à cocarde chirac était
ministre d'intérieur etc
henri amouroux vous savez les lycéens
qui m'a raconté cette histoire il est un
ami personnel des chaban delmas et il
est dans la cuisine en train de discuter
avec madame chaban delmas et chaban
delmas dans le salon avec chirac chirac
sort à ce moment-là chaban delmas
arrivent et leur disent mes amis c'est
gagné chirac est avec nous et en fait le
chirac est venu lui dire qu'il était
avec lui alors qu'il préparait déjà le
ce qu'on a appelé le coût des 43
c'est-à-dire l'appel des députés
gaullistes en faveur de gilles guérin a
dit dans tu deviens pas présent dans la
mêlée par hasard and voilà alors il ya
un truc aussi incroyable que j'ai appris
en lisant votre bouquin c'est qu'en fait
chirac est très cultivé
il a une culture très particulière non
mais c'est fou il avait écrit en 54 une
traduction de pouchkine il avait traduit
eugène onéguine et tout à fait il a
compris que finalement en démocratie les
gens préféraient le médiocre le mec qui
a un peu comme vous plutôt que le mec
qui vous prend de haut parce qu'il est
plus cultivé c'est fou ça moi je pense
que chirac et c'est très intéressant
parce que chirac se sert de ces failles
de c2c de ses complexes ce qui ne
s'aiment pas parce qu'ils se trouvent
pas très intelligent pour rouler les
ceux qui se croient très intelligent et
ce car balladur et c est par ailleurs il
me semble qu'il a compris le le côté
noir de la démocratie qui est cette
identification aux médiocres et il s'en
sert c'est un peu le paysan de fernand
raynaud je suis paysan il joue là dessus
c'est volpone sur son lit de mort et
mourir et tout le monde se moque de lui
et chirac il joue ça et comme ça les
gens le trouvent sympa il trouve le
concept à quand le goût de gaye est en
fait il n'est pas du tout con il n'est
pas du tout sympa retraite
marans alors en 76 il quitte quitte
matignon alors là aussi roule tout le
monde il est premier ministre de giscard
d'estaing il démissionne en dix ans
j'arrête la politique médias giscard
j'arrête la politique vous n'entendrez
plus parler de moi j'arrête la politique
que je vais ouvrir une boutique
d'antiquités ou faire et nos loges et
giscard le croire ça que j'adore il y
avait tellement envie remet la naïveté
j'ai tellement envie de le croire
jusqu'à alors là là il fonde le rpr
voilà en 77 il est maire de paris le
premier maire élu depuis la commune
voilà et là vous parlez à ce moment là
vous parlez de sa fièvre acheteuse c'est
dire qu'il a un goût des cadeaux
incroyable c'est pour raconter ça serait
bien d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'il part
en voyage il va dans les boutiques à new
york qui va chez nike dévalisé il devant
des pointures aux gens et où il fait des
cadeaux à il fait des cadeaux sans arrêt
à tout le monde un peu comme le fils
unique à l'école qui va se faire des
copains quand il était petit sa maman
avait un grand paquet de bonbons dans
son sac et il prenait quand ils
voulaient faire un copain ils allaient
dans le sac de sa maman il prenait un
paquet de bonbons et des bonbons dans le
paquet et il les offre est floue à au
type qui voulait qu'il ya au petit
garçon ou une petite fille qui est
activée qui voulaient sympathisé et ben
chirac il est toujours resté ce petit
garçon ce fils unique il couvre de
cadeaux
les gens avec lesquels il va sympathiser
et même mieux que ça
il couvre de cadeaux et ils couvrent
d'honneur de prébendes de pouvoir les
gens qu'il craint balladur ouais il a
peur de balladur il le couvre de pouvoir
il le couvre d'honneur il le coupe de
et parce qu'il en a peur grand père à
cette époque là quand ils offraient des
bonbons
cette personne vous raconter aussi son
goût pour les endroits paradisiaques
comme l'île maurice ça vient d'où ça
vous savez c'est un d'abord il ya
plusieurs choses
je pense que c'est un c'est un jouisseur
c'est un type qui veut qui veut profiter
de la vie
vous savez la politique c'est à la fois
toute sa vie et il méprise la politique
c'est les deux à la fois il n'a que ça
espèce de fuite en avant deux pour pour
pour échapper à son à son moi ça ses
angoisses et et en même temps ils
méprisent les politiques puisqu'il se
méprisent lui-même
donc ils méprisent les ceux qui sont
comme lui et donc il a besoin de
s'évader de s'évader de bernadette aussi
ouais
soyons soyons honnêtes donc c'est un peu
tout ça en 80 donc et la présidentielle
il fait perdre giscard devenu évident si
wallace et il est responsable de ça 86
ça va vous parler des relations et balla
diouf a une phrase que je vais citer
parce qu'elle est
chirac croit balladur trop intelligent
pour être un homme d'action et balladur
pense que chirac est trop rustique pour
faire un homme d'état tiers chacun à une
fausse idée de l'autre est une espèce de
jeu comme ça de tango très mal cinq
équipes qui commencent entre eux il y en
a qui s'imposent
intellectuellement c'est balladur bien
entendu mais loïc prise incroyablement
ce à des prix incroyables et il lui dit
mais croyez vous que ce soit très
intelligent de dire ça j'ai ce sit-in
oui mais c'est à dire vous et balladur
et l'autre qui s'impose physiquement
c'est chirac absolument qu'il a la
carrure il va tout à fait vous savez je
raconte contre vie balladur est malade
il est tout le temps malade balladur
santé très fragile et chirac lui dit
vous allez voir je vais vous préparez un
petit remontant à ma façon il lui mais
je sais pas combien d'alcool de mélanger
tout et autres balladur dirhams dont
jacques nom jacques et cc c'est la
castafiore et autres biens alors que
huit ça c'est quand même un truc
important dans votre bouquin et c'est ça
que le monde a repris cette semaine
parce que c'est c'est quand 88 donc
chirac que rencontre jean marie le pen
dans l'appartement de ghislain de
bénouville
le connaissez le vieux résistant la mine
mitterrand et de dassault voilà qui
était le bras droit de dassault alors
vous dites dans votre bouquin que la
rencontre a été initiée par charles
pasqua et dans le monde ont dit que non
alors je jeu ils ont raison j'ai commis
une petite confusion qui a eu deux
rencontres une organisé par pasqua chez
un de ses amis et l'autre chez
bénouville et comme pasqua m'a confirmé
les deux rendez vous j'ai opéré une
confusion j'étais persuadé que les deux
avaient été avait été préparé par pasqua
commet plus pasqua propose à chirac à ce
moment là un véritable accord politique
avec le pen c'est ce qui explique un peu
ma confusion mais voilà donc pasqua veut
qu'ils aient une alliance comme le
montre entre chirac et le pen et ça
s'est pas fait non la thèse de pasqua
c'est de dire on va le faire entrer dans
le système est le système le bouffera
oui ce que mitterrand avait été comme
exactement c'est exactement ça il faut
lui retirer son aura sulfureuse et or si
c'était le baiser de la mort exactement
alors le pen dit en parlant de chirac ce
jour là il ne m'a pas paru un homme
libre il m'a paru un homme piloter qui
obéit aux consignes du lobby voilà alors
le pen n'a chef vous savez je crois que
cette période est cruciale pour
comprendre la haine de le pen à l'égard
de chirac je crois que le pen et est un
personnage complexe toujours pris entre
sa volonté de se marginaliser de
provoquer qu'on connaît bien et une
partie qu'on connaît moins bien qui est
un besoin viscéral de respectabilité
sociale et il a cru à un moment que
chirac allait lui offrir cette
possibilité là vous savez jusqu'au
dernier moment entre les deux tours de
la présidentielle il est collé à son
téléphone le pen et il attend un coup de
fil de chirac il est persuadé que l'aude
à le faire rentrer dans le jeu et comme
il a eus ces rendez vous c'est ça que je
comprenais pas ça que j'ai découvert
pour ce livre pourquoi il lui est autant
mais je comprends il ya eu deux
rendez-vous en quinze jours le club fait
miroiter le truc à la ville elle a
laissé son bord de la route est
exactement
c'est vrai qu'une photo sur la plage où
ils sont tous les deux oui mais ça c'est
autre chose
ah bon c'est une rencontre en vacances
ensemble voilà c'est une rencontre
anodine et comme chirac un jour dit
celui qui sert la main de le pen se
déshonore le pen prend un coup de sang
envoie cette photo qui n'a rien à voir
avec les vraies rencontres
mais pour dire si tu continues je
balancerai ouais alors il ya une
fascination s'en doutait un peu mais
c'est bien raconté dans votre bouquin
une vraie fascination en revanche de
chirac pour mitterrand qui est une
espèce
c'est assez juste c'est une espèce
d'autres lui même mais aboutit quoi qui
aurait réussi oui exactement
je crois que chirac à a trouvé son
maître son père son modèle espèce de
jouer exactement de lui même abouti
il ya beaucoup de points communs entre
chirac et mitterrand beaucoup plus qu'on
croit ces deux grands aventuriers du du
pouvoir c'est de ce cynique absolu de ma
vie qu socialiste d'une certaine c'est
exactement deux opportunistes avec à la
fin du 19è mieux qu on appelait ça des
opportunistes et c'était pas c'était pas
méprisant à les calmer et chirac
simplement n'est pas un lettré comme
mitterrand
c'est là c'est la différence essentielle
c'est pas il fait des coups alors que
l'autre à des stratégies
mais chirac si on veut comprendre ce que
fait chirac depuis dix ans il suffit de
regarder ce qu'a fait mitterrand il le
il le singe jusque mai et quand il a
accepté enfin il n'a pas accepté mais
quand il s'est trouvé en face de
cohabitation il a pensé qu'ils
pourraient faire avec jose pas ce que
mitterrand avait fait avec lui sa loi
oui il dit en citant le bain
la cohabitation c'est génial je l' ai
connu comme premier ministre
mais maintenant je serai un président ça
sera sans moi le supérieur est aussi
plus dit oui mais jospin va avoir cinq
ans et on sera [ __ ] et chirac éclate
de réédit pour monique et il faut se
lever de bonne heure alors défaite en 88
foudroyé en plein vol évidemment parce
que là ils pensaient bien gagner ce coup
là c'était là il pensait pas gagner mais
il pensait pas être aussi humilié 46%
contre 54% sais c'est grotesque c'est
dur en 95 c'est la victoire est là
effectivement alors il nous la vend
fracture sociale
les guignols l'appeler le le tchi à la
place issus du che aujourd'hui c'est
chevènement le che là c'était le tchi
donc voilà la fractionner j'ai vu qu'il
a recommencé cette semaine un million
social est vraiment sans vergogne parce
que le 26 octobre
95 il va à canossa et il dit mais c'est
deux choses absolument extraordinaire
série je me souvenais plus de cette
phrase donc il dit je change ma
politique économique on allait faire un
truc un peu en dehors de l'europe une
politique différente des autres
européens etc
et puis ils changent d'avis 26 octobre
il dit j'avais sans doute sous-estimé
les difficultés budgétaires ce qui est
quand même pour un président la
république et c'est même plus
extraordinaire que ça vous me permettez
parce que d'abord c'est toujours c'est
toujours chirac qui se révoltent contre
l'establishment et petty qui recule et
qui se soumet c'est toujours la même
chose mais en fait c'est pas le 26
octobre qu'il a changé d'avis c'est dès
juin oui c'est ça que j'ai découvert
quand il a viré madelin mais malin c'est
partir mais même avant même avant en
juin juppé fait les arbitrages et les
arbitrages ils sont déjà dans l'euro
ouais donc des joints 95 c'est fini et
fin octobre les gens s'en rendent compte
mais dès juin s'est terminée en fait en
nommant juppé il avait déjà fait son
choix
ouais alors sur la question juive c'est
un peu comme le gaullisme il s'en fout
un peu tout ça enfin c'est pas c'est pas
trop son problème
en revanche c'est lui qui fait le
discours ou vel d'hiv sur la culpabilité
de la france par rapport aux juifs
pendant l'occupation c'est un geste
qu'on a attendu de mitterrand pendant de
longues années et qui n'a jamais fait
donc chirac le fait et puis en fait on
s'aperçoit que c'est claude chirac quand
même beaucoup insisté et vous dites dans
votre bouquin qu'il avait été perverti
d'une certaine façon par par mitterrand
c'est à dire c'est comme quand
mitterrand utilisé
sos racisme en 88 comme caisse de
résonance il ya deux choses il ya d'une
part chirac et c'est comme le gaullisme
le racisme c'est si j'ose dire sans
évidemment je compare pas mais c'est
pour dire qu' il s' à lui ça le concerne
pas c'est d'ailleurs assez admirable
c'est un truc qui ne rentre même pas
dans son esprit de racisme quoi il s'en
fout complètement
pour lui vraiment ça pose pas de
problème ça c'est une première chose est
alors maintenant c'est sur le plan
politique sur le plan politique il a
compris en regardant mitterrand qui a
perverti un peu tout ça avec sos racisme
avec carpentras il a compris comment
utiliser cette question là et
effectivement avec le discours sur le
vel d'hiv
il s'en sert et il dit d'ailleurs ce
qu'il est toujours dans l'autodérision
il ya un ami juif qui s'approche de lui
un peu un peu ému et qui lui dit bon
j'espère que les juges sont contents
parce que là je peux pas aller plus loin
ouais mais il faut prendre ça au
deuxième degré avec chirac tout et au
deuxième degré souvent un sens quand
même - oui mais ils se moquent tueur de
lui-même
ouais c'est moi qui peux pas faire plus
a par se convertir au cabba mais s'est
pourvu d'écriture lucide sur lui même
est ce son cynisme politicien sec
extraordinaire alors vous décrivez comme
un caméléon
vous dites chirac c'est le kouchner de
l'humanitaire personnel et quand ils
rencontrent quelqu'un il commença va
votre femme et vos enfants le chien il
m'emmène les nouvelles du chiendent
c'est vraiment maintenant il fait il
fait mieux quand c'est un bouquin qui
n'a pas lu le pose sur la table et il
met des petits postic dans les pages
importantes et a pas lu une ligne
ou alors il dit attends attends attends
c'est très intéressant ce que tu dis je
vais prendre des notes dans le tipi sort
de l'elysée le président république a
pris des notes sur ce qui dit il est au
septième ciel ils sont fous complètement
il fait ça tout le monde sait les
fordistes du métier mais d'ailleurs il
le dit il le dit pour lui la politique
c'est un métier et c'est un
professionnel il n'ya pas d'affect chez
chirac
voilà on va on va dire c'est la guerre
avec jospin et où c'est du pipeau il n'a
aucune aucune gêne pour jeu pour jospin
il n'a aucune peine pour personne c'est
c'est un boulot c'est ce week-end c'est
mon boulot de vendeuse exactement pas de
pas de vie privée puisque toute façon il
bosse tout le temps dont jours et demi
donc c'est pour ça quand on l'accuse des
fois utilisé l'argent de l'état à son
profit
c'est compliqué parce que tu as an il
bosse tout le temps passe et que voilà
et alors vous dit il c'est que le
bonheur n'existe pas je crois que c'est
un type profondément malheureux
profondément anxieux qui doutent de lui
même comme je n'ai cessé de le dire
et oui c'est il n'est pas heureux bah
oui c'est un type sol qui n'a aucun ami
oui oui c'est ça un jour il cherche des
amis elle ne sait plus pourquoi c'est
pourquoi pour une émission de télé
oui et son conseiller de communication à
l'époque cherche
on veut faire un la télé veut faire à
une émission dans un restaurant canaille
une brasserie à la mode et ses copains
est en fait mitterrand la gitane voilà
exactement
et en fait ils trouvent personne et donc
les ramènent non parce qu'il n'a aucun
ami c'est ça la chose termine avec mono
et frites ça se termine avec une manne
qui sont vraiment dommage qu il a fait
l'ena ya 40 s'est pas vraiment c'est pas
des amis alors on vous dit en conclusion
c'est assez peut-être finalement ce
qu'on peut dire de pire parce que dit de
pierre édile a ignoré l'avertissement du
général de gaulle qui a déclaré l'
aventure personnelle est une passion
enfantine c'est à dire qu'effectivement
il est resté dans une aventure
personnelle qui lui a bien réussi dans
tous les cas fait très bien oui mais
c'est une passion enfantine c'est une
espèce de c'est toujours le fils unique
qui veut tous les jouets quitte à les
casser après ouais mais il est toujours
dans ce rapport là il ya un truc est pas
dans votre bouquin avec des mots mais
quelque chose qu'elle vous avez sûrement
des informations c'est la démission du
juge halphen qui dit j'ai tellement été
on m'a tellement cherché on m'a
tellement fils est pris en photo avec
eux avec ma compagne et c'est que
finalement il finit par démissionner
donc le mec non seulement il a été
dessaisie de la faire le jeu est fun
mais en plus c'est obligé de
démissionner il n'est pas obligé bas
obligé oui en prenant bruit dans la rue
mais non non non non bien sûr et je
crois qu'effectivement si vous voulez le
juge halphen c'est compliqué parce que
je ne suis pas un juriste donc je suis
pas mais ce qu'on me dit c'est qu'il a
il n'a pas été très rigoureux
une api là il a fait des maladresses et
s'est du coup les chiraquiens et les les
repères jeandebon avocat voilà et ont
profité de ça et effectivement à d'après
ce qu'on me dit aussi il a été quand
même quelque peu harcelée sur sa vie
privée sa sphère maréchal déjà pour
commencer à faire maréchal enfin bon le
beau père oui il est pas très très droit
je vais être méchant mais c'est lui qui
a proposé un ouais c'est quand même lui
qui a proposé de toucher un million pour
apprendre pour pour faire un mauvais
coup ce sera avec son goût avec son
genre ce que je peux avoir un pull
en étonne
eric zemmour
comment vous l'auteur des rats de garde
avec patrick poivre d'arvor qui est un
ouvrage sur la presse people et des
paparazzi comment vous pouvez dans votre
bouquin parler du suicide de laurence la
fille aînée des chirac qui était
anorexique et qui est une sorte d'
enfant caché du couple est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est bien pour le suicide
de laurence bernadette elle-même en
parle donc sa mère et deuxièmement je
faisais un portrait de chirac ce n'est
pas un livre théorique politique
c'était un portrait de l'homme je
voulais faire un roman l'espèce de roman
vrai de jacques chirac comme un
personnage romanesque et donc j'avais
besoin de montrer
toutes les facettes de ce type et
justement pour expliquer ce que vous
avez remarqué tout à l'heure c'est à
dire qu'il sait que le bonheur n'existe
pas et que c'est un type profondément
malheureux je pense que le drame que vit
sa fille
fais partie de ceux de ce malheur
profond vous savez je raconte aussi une
scène quand pasqua
vous savez quand elle se suicide elle
est à l'hôpital et le premier le premier
à venir
c'est pasqua alors qu'ils sont en guerre
politique et que les chinois sont
entaillés lors de ce moment là les
chercheurs thaïlandais qui reprennent
l'avion et les passe quoi bon les veillé
toute la nuit et quand pasqua sort de
l'hôpital parce qu'on a dit
vraiment on peut rencontrer ce qu'on
veut à chirac mais il porte sa croix
il sait que sa fille est malade parce
qu'il a fait de la politique on rallume
[Musique]
je le savais pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu